el guapo ya que va a comprar un pony de
diamantes el poni cuesta de pesos y ya
que también tiene que pagar un impuesto
del 25 por ciento sobre los ponis de
diamante o el pony de diamante que va a
comprar as coincidir las expresiones con
sus significados cada significado puede
coincidir con más de una expresión bueno
tenemos que nuestro primer significado
es el precio del pony de diamantes antes
de impuestos no nos están diciendo que
cuesta pesos así que la p que es el
precio del pony va acá la segunda es la
cantidad de impuestos que tiene que
pagar ya que bueno nos dicen que los
impuestos son el 25 por ciento sobre el
precio del pont y así quede lo que sea
que cueste el pony está pe se tiene que
pagar un 25 por ciento de esto otra
forma de verlo es que este impuesto es
igual a punto 25 por p
este es el impuesto bueno
el tercer significado cantidad total que
pagó jacques por el pony bueno pues
esencialmente va a ser el precio del
pony más lo de impuestos que tiene que
pagar
así que este más punto 25 por p ésta
coincide pero si nos fijamos en las
demás vemos que esto es punto 25 p es lo
mismo que 1.25 por p así que ésta
también coincide y las otras tres
expresiones pues no coinciden con lo que
nos están preguntando así que las
ponemos en ninguna de éstas
vamos a checar nuestra respuesta en
efecto todo está correcto